Speaker 1: The Republicans civil war is not
letting up any time soon. In fact, it's growing
Republican. You know, I don't I don't want to say
insider, but establishment Republican Paul Ryan, a
major figure in the last, you know, ten, 15 years
of Republican politics, is now openly saying.
We will lose if Trump is the nominee. I
am anti-Trump and I will not go to the
Republican National Convention in 2024 if Donald
Trump is indeed the nominee. Let's take a look
at a couple of very interesting clips. Here
is Paul Ryan speaking at the Tommy Thompson
Center on Public Leadership. And he says,
I'm not for Trump because I want to win.
Speaker 2: I'm a never again Trumper because I
want to win. We're going to lose with him. Look,
the evidence is pretty clear. We lost the house
in 18 because of Trump. We lost the presidency,
obviously in 20 because of Trump. We lost the
Senate in 20 because of Trump. Then there are I,
by my count, five Senate seats this cycle and
22 we lost because of Trump. And by most sort
of smart people in our party, by most of
their measurements, we lost about 12 to
15 seats in the House because of Trump. So Kevin
McCarthy, what had a nice 20 some vote cushion,
had an op ed for Trump. So the point I'm making
is we know we lose with him and so we know we
will lose with him again if we nominate this guy.
And January six happened after the 20 election.
So you think he became more popular with
four swing voters in the Wall counties,
you know, since January six. So my point is
we're going to lose with the guy. So let's.
Speaker 1: Now, is Paul Ryan correct about
this? I actually don't know. I mean, listen,
if you look at the latest polling, it doesn't
look terrible for Trump assuming he can win
the Republican nomination. You look at
a recent Emerson College poll released,
released, I think today, taken February 24th and
25th, is an A-minus rated pollster on Biden versus
Trump. They have Trump plus three in the popular
vote. It's February, almost March of 2023. So you
could say this isn't really worth much, but it is
not obvious that Trump can't win if he does become
the nominee in 2024. Morning Consult, which is a
B rated pollster, has Biden plus two against Trump
in an Echelon Insights poll Has Biden plus three
over Trump. The point is, it's not a foregone
conclusion that Donald Trump can't defeat Joe
Biden if that's the rematch of 2020 and 2024. But
Paul Ryan's opinion is that Trump can't win and
he wants to win. Now, we have a couple of other
clips. Here is Paul Ryan being interviewed
by Fox six and he is continuing to pile on.
Speaker 2: I'm backing the person not named
Donald Trump, so I don't really have a dog
in the fight other than that, if we nominate
Trump again, we're going to lose again. It's
just that clear. We lost with him in 1820 and 22.
We know this. He will cost us another election.
So I'm just excited about somebody not named.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And then just one more clip
here of Paul Ryan saying he will
not attend the Republican National
Convention if Trump is the nominee for the.
Speaker 2: Republican National Convention in
Milwaukee. Where will you be? And it depends
on who the nominee is. I'll be here. If it's
somebody not named Trump, you won't show up. If
it's not, I'm not interested in participating in
that. No. Even in Wisconsin. Even Wisconsin.
Speaker 1: So, listen, there's really let's
there's two parts to this. There's the Republican
Civil War aspect to it, and there's the can Trump
win aspect, which we don't have a definitive
answer to right now. The Civil War part continues
to be very interesting, where you see people
in the vein of Paul Ryan, Mitt Romney, Adam
Kinzinger and others who have the I hate to call
it audacity. They just have the sort of honesty,
I guess, to say what we know more Republicans than
just them are thinking. They don't care if they
are on the outs when it comes to being friendly
with those who are in positions of power if Trump
wins and Trump's in power. We all know Paul Ryan
will have no influence. Mitt Romney will have
no influence, and they're okay with that for one
reason or another. Fine. Okay. That that's nope,
no problem whatsoever. The question of listen.
In 18. Republicans did poorly because of Trump.
In 20, they lost the Senate and they lost the
presidency. And then in 22, the red wave that
was supposed to be actually saw them lose a seat
in the Senate and take the slimmest of minorities
in the House. Trump's been a disaster. Completely
true. The reason I wouldn't count out Trump in 24
if he is indeed the nominee is when you are out
of power and you are making the argument things
are terrible and you've got to put me back in to
fix it. As transparent as that is, as you and I,
of course, know. Just like Trump made all these
promises he didn't keep in 2016 and just like
he wouldn't have kept the promises he made in
2020, he's not going to do any of the things
he's going to do. He's not going to fix any of the
problems that he claims he's going to fix if he
wins in 24. But being on the outside and being
able to say everybody in power is ruining it,
bring me in and I will fix it. That can actually
motivate people who otherwise wouldn't vote at all
to vote. And that may actually be what the 24
election hinges on. So I would not assume that
Trump can't win. And I think that it would be
a very big mistake to do what many did in 2016,
which is to laugh off the idea of Trump.
At least now we know he did once win.
And that should remind us he could win again. But
the Civil War aspect of this is going to become
very interesting, particularly as more candidates
announce that they are going to be running against
Trump in that Republican primary race. So we're
going to continue following all of it. I do want
to invite you to subscribe to the YouTube channel
at YouTube.com slash The David Pakman Show. We do
desperately need your help in getting to that
2 million subscriber number. And I also want to
remind you, we are now dubbing roughly two thirds
of our daily content into the Spanish language
elements of Spanish you can find on the Spanish
channel at David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.
Let your friends, neighbors, parents, cousins,
anybody who is looking for this type of content,
but in Spanish rather than English, let them
know David Pakman dot com slash Spanish.